Frédéric Estienne est depuis toujours un
grand fan de moto
dès que la neige est disparaît la saison
commence et depuis l'arrivée en février
de la nouvelle plateforme en ligne ça
clique et possible pour lui
d'immatriculer son nouveau véhicule
j'arrive sur la démarche de la SAQ c'est
simplement disponible pour faire un
remisage ou pour faire un renouvellement
de permis donc toutes ces démarches pour
rien il ne pourra finalement mettre la
main sur ses immatriculations que moi
plus tard faut de plage de rendez-vous
disponibles dans une succursale près de
chez lui donc c'était le 19 avril et on
m'offrait le 19 mai mais pas de date
intermédiaire avant ça deux mois après
la difficile implantation de sa clé au
Québec de nombreux usagers s'impatiente
et je trouve c'est mal organisé ça
fonctionne pas parce que ça a l'air que
mon nom est pas écrit comme il faut
surtout les différents documents j'ai
essayé ce sort de prendre un rendez-vous
en ligne mais le prochain rendez-vous
était en mi-juillet à la Société de
l'assurance automobile du Québec on
répond qui est en toujours en période de
stabilisation avons vu l'ampleur d'un
tel projet nous apportons en continu des
améliorations nous veillons à régler les
cas des clients dès qu'ils nous sont
soumis la SAQ dit aussi accompagner ses
clients en messagerie privée sur
Facebook ou encore par courriel depuis
le 28 février c'est plus de 1,8 millions
de clients qui ont été servis dans
l'ensemble du Québec dont plus de 780
000 en ligne via cette clique
peut-être un moment discutable donc en
pleine période de pointe après une
fermeture de plusieurs semaines
sans avoir je crois suffisamment penser
aux impacts que ça pourrait avoir sur le
client et sur l'employé même si beaucoup
d'améliorations ont été observées dans
les différents points de services de la
SAQ Frédéric Etienne dit tout de même se
sentir pris en otage par un système qui
tente de se moderniser ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal